muito bom dia não sei se vocês sabem mas
já estamos em campi novamente para a
próxima luta do w e nesse vídeo a gente
vai mostrar a dieta do Whindersson Então
vamos começar na refeição um são oito da
manhã a gente faz tudo pesadinho a
primeira refeição dele
vai ser um shake de proteína com 30g de
proteína isolada
[Música]
aí beleza eu posso um pouquinho mais
tranquilo 20 gramas de aveia
mas
30 g de leite em pó desnatado
deu certinho
e ele tá dormindo ainda
que a gente vai ter que ir lá no quarto
dele acordar ele que é a pior parte a
parte mais difícil
então a gente coloca tudo aqui ó
liquidificador
eu vou pegar água e o gelo
colocar mais
lembrando lá vem as mãos de cozinha
certinho agora pessoal vamos manipulados
é muita coisa não dá para ficar mais
ômega 3
ferro
articulação manipulado para articulação
Bom dia
isso é um blog da rotina da dieta do
Wilson pessoal
café da manhã já contou para a galera
muito bastidores
osteoporose
[Música]
memória
aí vê cara bebe no artrose
uma blusa para ele correr que hoje em
dia depois do tenente vai correr na hora
porque 15 minutos vamos contar até 10 se
chegar no 10 ele não levantar ele não
vai ser mais rico
um dois três
quatro cinco
seis sete
agora é a segunda refeição do dia né que
é o almoço
primeiro prato é todo de
salada legumes
a galera
e tal fica grande também então tem que
maneirar eu como esse aqui e depois vem
a proteína
e o carpinho
pesado Então tem que tem um carrozinho
porque senão
aguenta
cenoura
brócolis cenoura e Vagem hoje né aí
amanhã pode ser
alface e como é o nome daquele Branco
repolho eu não quero nem ver não
[Música]
a cenoura
cenoura tem beta
cenoura tem muito isso eu que sou
desprovido né Assim
é bom cenouras beterraba
pigmentaçãozinha para gente
natureza né
a vagem é o feijão do ansioso
aí Aqui tem tudo pesado tá 100 gramas de
arroz Quantos gramas de arroz
100 g de arroz de feijão
30 g de feijão quanto de carne
sem o 120 de carne
Esse é o meu almoço entendeu por causa
do treino de hoje cada cada refeição
conta da exigência de cada treino né
com
misto né
Tem muita informação não é presunto
queijo botar mais coisa e já tá
com fome mas ela tá querendo é brincar
tirar onda agora
beleza respeito pode comer aí também mas
aí você só fala isso
a janta do Whindersson Nunes segue o
padrão do almoço
100 gramas de arroz
Então a gente tem
30 gramas de feijãozinho que ele come o
preto que é o que ele prefere aí a gente
tem também
150 gramas de filé de frango
será que vai dar um beijo
eu acho que vai passar um pouquinho para
te engolir
aí agora eu vou botar no microfone
[Música]
esse aqui galera
é o seguinte ele cobra uma salada a
vontade antes do prato que é o que está
escrito no ar aí a salada é a montagem
aí eu já quero alface e cenoura
e a pizza
[Música]
a cidade mais importante daquela parte
qualquer cidadão Romana desta época na
produção de alimentos como dança de
estratégia é a decisão de não conquistar
novas terras a partir do século II
[Música]